Hello Freak bitches,
you know all that power already.
Like why would he,
why would he want to be the president?
It just seems like such
a fucking helacious job.
Unless he really feels like he can fix
things or he's really gonna make a ton of
money from it.
I mean this is a guy who plasters his,
his fucking name on buildings and Shit,
you know.
So I think it's really just a matter for
him of like, this is part of my legacy.
You know, towards the end of my life
I was president of the United States.
It's so weird.
It's so weird cause it's,
it's another version of what many people
did with Obama in this weird way in
that when Obama got into office,
there was all these, a really,
really rational people that said all
kinds of crazy shit. And by the way,
Trump was amongst them.
He was a birther. Yeah,
he was a member for the longest time. He
was convinced. Somebody convinced him.
I Dunno who convinced him.
I Dunno if you've ever really relinquished
it and realize that it was wrong or
if he still holds onto the idea. Did he
ever really believe it too? I don't know.
You know, I don't know. But you know
who started that whole birth of thing?
Hillary Clinton. Yeah, she
did. That's right. That's
something that people forget.
It was during the,
uh,
the campaign between her and a Obama when
they were trying to get the nomination
in 2008. Yeah. Yeah. She, she had,
well she had one of her little org
send out materials that you know,
showed Obama and like the,
like he was wearing like some
African Muslim garb. Shit.
Cause he went on a visit to some other
company. You look at him, you know,
he's Muslim and uh,
you know,
and Trump just ran with that. Yeah. Or a
lot of Republicans did to cause, you know,
well I guess that's just how they play
politics. They have some like that,
they just run with it.
It's just so strange to see when you
got a candidate named Barack Obama.
I know,
you know it's easy Hussain who saying
Obama like Barack Hussein Obama Sane in
that the guy you know
ran a racket and Obama,
it had the similar to the name of the
guy that crashed those planes into the
towers and yeah, somebody had a
Joe really good, well wrote a joke.
I don't remember who it was though.
It might've been 20 inch
glove but I mean it's just,
this is almost a s a similar reaction.
I don't mean it's less,
it's more rational or less rational.
What I mean is almost like
the energy of the reaction,
like the energy of the birthers and the
guys who were convinced that he was some
sort of undercover Muslim and then he
was going to get into the White House and
tried to take America
down from the inside.
Like that feeling that the amount of
energy that way is mirrored now on the
left. Maybe even though, yeah,
maybe even past I would say probably I
might not be right cause I might not be
remembering it perfectly.
But I feel like the energy on the left
of people getting mad at Trump is more
powerful or more,
there's more to it than the energy
that I saw from people on the right.
They wanted Obama out of office,
but it might just be my memory.
And you got to remember too, there's like
an age gap there. Yeah. Cause you know,
most of the people who were talking that
shit about Obama were, were pretty old.
Right, right. And a lot of the people
now that are pissed or really young,
so they're more likely to take
to the streets and you know,
smash things and hold
up signs and you know,
act wild and shit and mace people.
Yeah.
And I perspire when Bush took
office though, like when Bush, uh,
was, was being inaugurated, I remember
he was driving down, uh, to the,
to the White House during the inauguration
day. And they were, you know, with,
with Trump, the protesters kinda
came the next day. But with,
when Bush was inaugurated, the protesters
were all there the day of. And you know,
Bush couldn't even do the
little traditional walk
down the last few blocks of
the,
the journey because there was so many
protestors and people were just throwing
things at the fucking motor Cade and shit.
So I mean like this is not unusual,
but that was towards the end.
No, that was the very beginning.
What am I, which 1:00 AM I thinking of?
Wasn't there one towards the very end that
I think we're thinking of different ones.
Okay. I think I'm, my memory's fucked up,
but I think there was one towards the
end where they had planned on having him
walk down some long stretch and they
had to abandon it and get them into car.
Is that the same stores? Uh, yeah.
Well I think that was both times.
I think it was the first,
but even during his first time,
like when he was just first
being inaugurated president
in 2000 so right after
Clinton, like that inauguration was
bad. It was almost the same. Yeah,
it was terrible.
It was almost the same as what you see
now because people had had this Democrat
in power for eight years
and they thought like, yeah.
And they thought Gore is a shoe in because
Clinton's popular just same as like
Hillary's a shoe in because Obama's
popular. Right. But you know,
a Republican ended up taking it and,
and they just freaked out.
And it seems like that
always just happens.
I mean like this kind of like backlash,
like it always is kind of sold
to us as like this is new,
this is like, Oh wow, look
at what's going on now.
Isn't this crazy what crazy
times we live in? But it's,
I look back at my memories of the past
and it seems like this is pretty par for
the course. I think you're right.
Now that I'm thinking about it,
it's almost like we go through
these like cycles. Yeah.
And if a president gets past
one cycle removed from his,
his tenure,
then people forgive them.
They forget and they changed their
opinion. Yeah. Like Reagan, like, man,
when I was a kid,
Reagan was a pariah.
Like people were so upset about Reagan,
they were so upset.
And there was the contra versus Nicaragua,
uh,
trial that was on television with Oliver
North and we were finding out on TV,
like whether or not the government had
sold arms and lied about it and weather
then, you know, the,
the whole Reagan thing was the
one that Reagan sold arms to Iran,
the great Jimmy Tangle,
hilarious standup comedian in Boston has
this bit about it because they, well,
that was when Reagan started claiming
all timers or when he claimed memory
issues, which turned out to be
true. I mean, you really did.
I have memory issues and he probably
did it a time, but they asked him,
did you sell arms to Iraq? I said,
I don't know. And Jimmy Tangles,
like mister president,
if you ever sell to people,
hate us, jot it down,
was like, make a note,
put it on the refrigerator today.
I sold Amz to people who hate me.
You have to hear him. I mean, you know,
it, it, it, you have to realize though,
like America's always has been
a huge arms dealer. I mean,
we're constantly selling weapons.
Oh yeah. I mean like if he,
if he didn't remember why he did it,
it's probably because there were
just so many other transactions.
I don't think the president personally
gets involved too much in that sort of
stuff. But no, probably not.
Country sells weapons all over the
place and we continue to do that. Yeah.
My point was there like eight years later,
he was the great Ronald Reagan.
Oh yeah. Eight years late. Lion eyes
goes through the Clinton administration.
Everybody's done with Clinton getting
his dick sucked and the White House and
all that craziness. And, and
then as soon as that's over,
people start reminiscing to Reagan.
It's really interesting.
It's really interesting how we do it.
And so now Bush went through this period
of being hated and he's out of office
at Obama, goes through his period of
being hated for eight years. And now that,
and even more unreasonable Republicans
in office, people long to the Bush day.
Oh yeah.
Like you,
you notice their trot and
Bush out and keep doing
interviews with them. Like, Hey,
remember this war criminal
now he's okay. Well, he's,
he's uncle Bush Bush here,
uncle Bush going to set you on his knee.
They um,
super important.
What does that protests during the Bush
administration eyes and Augie aerations.
Yeah. Yup. Wow. What does it say
and fuck Bush. Oh, buck flush,
flush. There's a couple of years.
My President of course, man,
of course. So you know, this
is, this is all so cyclic. Yeah.
It just happens over and over again and
people think it's new and the, you know,
for some, I think, I guess it's,
it's the country just has a short
memory to what a crazy show.
This is what a crazy show we're watching
the battle to control the world.
Yeah. Political Theater, pageantry.
But you know, like it's just,
I mean like I don't want to get into like
you already had Alex Jones on the show,
so I can't really get in to that
level of territory. But I mean,
I do agree that these
parties are constantly just
working together behind the
scenes,
and that 90% of the issues they agree on,
they just make a big spectacle of the
little things they actually disagree on.
To distract us with a show.
You look, America, look,
look at us. We're fighting.
We're fighting. Right?
How'd they stopped paying
attention? Okay, now we've made it.
Now we do the real deals. Who are we
going to bomb? Who are we going to invade?
You know, uh, who are we going to
sell weapons to? Whatever. Yeah.
Yeah.